[Music]  clearly happily-ever-after is not in the  cards for Pam Anderson and her ex Tommy  Lee  Pam stepped out last night with her son  Brandon in the midst of their very  public family feud making zero attempt  to fly under the radar a source tells ET  this mother-son dinner was to show a  quote united front against Brandon's  father Tommy Lee three weeks ago Brandon  and Tommy were engaged in an altercation  that left his father with a bloody lip  Pamela was dressed in a skin-tight  little black dress with dainty matching  gloves brandon wore a red silk shirt  with the phrase blind for love the LA  Sheriff's Department tells ET the  criminal investigation is ongoing with  our source saying Tommy is being  stubborn and won't drop the case  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]